I want to create jobs of course you need
the sustainable economy you need the
development and you need the will the
will to work these are important factors
so that you can create jobs with you
need some projects we need the
developments the growth the growth in
and of course that world need to grow
and they are growing because of the
young society we have probably fifty
fifty percent or more of the people of
the inhabitants are below the age of 18
that that helps to grow the society the
unrepentant renewals they need to work
hard than a you need to this is the
success if you work very hard you can
reach you don't and you have to follow
up issues you have to be you have to be
on on on board so as not to miss the
opportunities
the youth youth make the youth can make
a lot of difference because they are the
backbone of the nation's and they can do
a great things by when they get together
and work as hard that they know what
they want to do they must have a plan
they must have a roadmap and coupled
with they must come up with ideas who in
order this ideas succeed thank you